Uh,
my name is Jonathan Macintosh and I do,
I do video remixes and I call
myself a pop culture hacker. Uh,
which basically means that I
pull apart fragments of TV,
movies, hop music. Um, I pulled them
apart and look for their deeper meanings,
um, look for the social and
cultural context and implication is,
and then put them back together to
create a new and alternative narratives.
Um, so it's really mixing
footage and mixing music,
but it's also real mixing
the message of that media.
I began remixing in 2003.
Um,
I was watching the US invasion of Iraq.
I was very upset about it.
Uh,
I was very angry about it and I was
watching the news every day, you know,
24 hours a day, pretty much,
you know, watching, watching,
and recording and also, um,
and after the first few days, they start
to put the commercials back in, you know,
that they had, this is what I have
the news report, the commercial,
the news report, the commercial.
Right. Um, and to me it became,
they started to become the same thing.
You know,
because many of the companies that make
the weapons also on the new station,
you know, um, and uh,
and so I started mixing those two together
and I made very short ads and they
were about the war and they were about
the US involvement in the war. And, uh,
the corporatization of war and the profit
that people were making off of that,
when you cross into the blue,
everything is different and important,
especially you.
I was being critical.
And then I also was very upset about the
way that the u s media covered the war
too. You know, they wouldn't
show anyone who was dead.
There was no impact really
in terms of, uh, of humanity.
And it was all about how
cool the weapons were.
Yeah.
For me, that was distasteful, but
it was also, I think the moral,
and so a lot of the remixes that I
made was to put those images back in.
So it's that, you know, mixing the ads
for, for cars or, or, um, you know,
toothpaste or whatever
with the news footage.
But then also bringing in some of the
documentary footage that we didn't see in
the u s um, of, of, of
people who had been killed.
Would you like to do with your life?
You want to be like the good guys
riding around? No, to be honest,
I want to be the bad guy.
Real bad guys.
Bad guys at tie people up.
Trump
cares about the good guys,
bad guys.
They're the ones you may
go back to class now, Gary,
get strength for now. Strength
for later. Learn more@goarmy.com
TV, movies, news, right?
A politician's speeches.
They're part of the popular culture
and they're part of the way the,
the language we use to talk to each other.
You know,
we might meet for a coffee and say,
what did you see that on TV last night?
And you say, Oh yeah, yeah, I saw
that. And we talk about it, right?
It's a common language.
The common ground through which we can
talk about larger issues, you know, race,
gender, class, a war, right?
And we can do it in a
language that's audio visual.
We don't have to speak the words
so we don't have to use text,
but we can also use the videos
themselves or the audio itself. Um,
as a way of communicating.
One of the projects that I've been doing
with, um, young people, Middle School,
so like 11, 12 years old, um, uh, I've,
I've recorded a bunch of TV ads
directed at kids for Gi Joe, for Barbie,
for Polly pocket, you know, all these
toys and brought them into the classroom.
And, and, and we,
and these workshops and the young people
look at them and then we talk about
them. What are the boys doing? What are
the girls doing? The boys though are,
are creating and they're building
and they're making things,
but they're also being quite violent. You
know, a lot of, a lot of military stuff.
Um, a lot of competition,
a lot of aggression, right?
Whereas on the other side,
the young,
young women in those ads are being caring
and nurturing and some positive stuff
too.
So we talk about all that.
And then I have the kids remix the ads.
You know,
just take the audio from the girls' ads
and put it on the video of the boys ads
for five years,
it's suddenly become incredibly
apparent. You know, it's just,
it's really obvious to everyone and
everyone sort of laughing and, right.
But you're also seeing it,
you're seeing what they're doing,
what they're telling you about gender,
you're seeing those gender stereotypes
and you're breaking them down and
creating something new right
now, a different vision. Um,
and so I find that is a very
powerful tool, uh, with, with youth.
And then when they,
when they go home,
hopefully when they go
home and watch TV again,
they can't watch it the same way
because they're always thinking, oh,
wouldn't that be interesting if these
two things are, what about that?
What does the message messaging
and what if I mixed it with this?
And wouldn't that be funny or interesting?
You know? Um, and so it's, it's creating,
um,
hopefully it's,
it's creating in the minds of young
people and more critical way of watching
television. We're in a dark, dark place.
We've got some dark dudes coming our way.
Alcaide ran Islamic Jihad
has breasts finish, Suede, immigration,
Mexicans, refugees, Spanish,
South America, legal, alien,
Mexico, China. Everyone is coming.
The enemy is not only in the
gates there inside the house,
again,
be at most come up Liam pestle.
Oh La Mex.
America.